Thinking of moving to another country in the European Union?
Did you know that your rights to a pension are protected?
Take Johann, he is German, working in his home country for ten years.
Now he’s decided to follow his passion for skiing and got a job in Austria.
So what happens to his pension rights?
His pension contributions remain in Germany -
they don’t get transferred or reimbursed.
Any contributions he makes in Austria will likewise remain in Austria.
Remember: Each country you live and work in will keep their own insurance records.
Two years later, Johann moves to France.
He settles down there and starts a family…
On reaching retirement age, Johann will make his claim in the country where he is living -
in this case in France.
The French authorities will liaise with the German and Austrian institutions
informing them of Johann's pension claim.
Johann receives a decision from each national institution,
and finally a document summarising the pension decisions made by all the countries involved.
Remember: when you reach pensionable age,
every country where you have been insured will pay you a separate pension.
Be aware that the conditions for entitlement,
such as the pensionable age and the amounts paid,
may differ from one country to another…
Johann reaches the pensionable age in France at 62 and in Austria at 65 years old
but won’t receive his German pension until he reaches the German pensionable age of 67.
But what happens if you don’t comply with the country-specific conditions for entitlement?
According to Austrian law,
Johann is not entitled to a pension
because he doesn’t fulfil the minimum requirement of 10 years of contributions.
Fortunately, Johann’s rights are protected by EU social coordination rules
that oblige countries to include periods worked in any EU country,
plus Iceland, Liechtenstein, Norway and Switzerland.
In Johann’s case, Austrian institutions will acknowledge his contribution periods
in France and Germany and pay him an amount proportional
for the two years he worked in Austria.
So whenever Johann decides to retire,
he will be entitled to receive his pension,
without losing any of his contributions.
Social security coordination enables you to move around Europe
and not lose out on your social security rights.